facciamo un po di meta narrazione
stasera sono sul palco del ted e
cercherò insieme a voi di spiegare quel
meccanismo che si cela dietro
l'affascinante ma al tempo stesso
complesso mondo della comunicazione
già perché per questa sigla è
innanzitutto una piattaforma che non
favorisce la discussione su determinati
argomenti ben si fa della comunicazione
stessa il suo punto di vista sul mondo e
sulla realtà comunicare parola nuova
come antica dal latino cum e munire
letteralmente legare insieme ma anche
fare partecipi il che tradisce le due
componenti nonché le due caratteristiche
principali della comunicazione legale
insieme perché comunicazione significa
unire parole in ordine logico in maniera
logica per trasmettere un messaggio e
quindi anche fare partecipe e l'altro di
un pensiero di un opinione di un
qualcosa che ci appartiene
oggi comunicazione fa rima con public
speaking una parola anch'essa moderna ma
che tradisce nella sua intima essenza o
qualcosa di antico infatti chiamatela
pure public speaking chiamate la
retorica chiamate dalla latina arte
retorica o alla greca retoriche tecne ma
la sostanza resta sempre quella la
retorica questa scienza questa tecnica
quest'arte che fu codificata dagli
antichi ma che oggi viene rispolverata
in moltissimi campi della quotidianità
dall'economia pensiamo ad esempio al
marketing o alla semplice pubblicistica
sino al mondo della politica dove i
politici tutti i giorni rispolverano non
per l'appunto le tecniche del mondo
antico degli antichi oratori e per
accattivarsi il bacino elettorale che è
di fatto il loro pubblico il loro
interlocutore e questo tradisce di per
sé
una cosa molto fondamentale che stasera
vorrei sottolineare ovvero il legame
naturale intrinseco tra l'uomo e la
parola la parola che quindi è
comunicazione che è pertanto l'esempio
più peculiare del fenomenico umano di
ciò che significa humanitas essere
uomini
non è un caso che le prime tracce di
retorica le troviamo proprio nell'ottavo
secolo avanti cristo nei celeberrimi
omerici ovvero l'iliade e l'odissea è
che in quegli stessi anni stesse
nascendo in grecia proprio la prima
forma di civiltà la prima forma di
società organizzata
le famose paul heyse dove capiamo subito
l'importanza che assumeva all'interno di
un contesto che forse democratico
oligarchico la capacità di persuadere di
convincere l'interlocutore nell'ambito
ovviamente politico delle decisioni per
la vita pubblica e quindi l'importanza
che imprescindibile che la retorica
iniziò ad assumere per il buon oratore e
di conseguenza per il buon politico per
la classe dirigente
il primo codificare questa scienza
quest'arte che è la retorica fu il
filosofo greco aristotele nel iv secolo
avanti cristo
nel libro che porta per l'appunto il
nome di retorica lui pose le basi del
modello retorico classico che è il
modello che sta ancora la base della
comunicazione di tutta la comunicazione
di oggi un modello che fu ripreso a roma
da cicerone comunemente considerato il
più grande oratore della latinità nonché
uno dei più complessi ma al tempo stesso
affascinanti e completi oratori della
storia del panorama dell'oratoria antica
come moderno e come contemporanea
il modello che cicerone codificò in
maniera quasi definitiva
nelle opere tecniche come il decoratore
fu ripreso poi nella prima età imperiale
da un retore non più oratore ma
semplicemente insegnante di retorica
delle tecniche che stanno alla base del
saper convincere e quindi della
buona comunicazione quintiliano
quintiliano che quindi lascio al
medioevo in eredità e successivamente
quindi anche all'età moderna e all'età
contemporanea nonché al post modello
dove viviamo oggi noi un modello
retorico completo e ben codificato che
sta tuttora la base della formazione e
che è stata la base della formazione di
tutte le classi dirigenti dall età greco
romana attraverso il medioevo l'età
moderna sino alle nostre classi
dirigenti per l'appunto
questo è il modello e il sistema
retorico di affidamento alla base di
tutte le comunicazioni quindi tutti gli
scambi interpersonali che attuiamo e che
mettiamo in pratica nella nostra
quotidianità ancora oggi e per farvi
capire l'attualità e la quotidianità
della retorica di questa materia sempre
viva vi porterò alcuni esempi quando
steve jobs fece il celebre discorso e
laureandi di stanford nel 2005 faceva
public speaking ora o retorica come
abbiamo detto le due parole sono
intercambiabili ma ancora quando barack
obama parla o parlava le nazioni te fa o
faceva public speaking e ancora e credo
ricorderete tutti quando marcello lippi
arringo i giocatori della nazionale
italiana prima dei rigori della celebre
finale del 2006 italia francia fece
public speaking quando voi ragazzi
chiedete alla nostra professoressa di
storia di spostata e l'interrogazione a
lunedì
fate public speaking disperato ma forse
altre public speaking e quindi ci
avviamo ad analizzare per l'appunto il
modello di cicerone che identifica
cinque momenti fondamentali della
realizzazione di una buona ora azione da
parte del bravo oratore essenzialmente
invenzioni sposizione lo curzio memoria
e axjo che poi analizzeremo abbastanza
dettagliatamente l'uno dopo l'altro
attraverso questo esempio funesto che ho
invocato poc'anzi l'interrogazione il
compito di storia da spostare e da
spostare assolutamente a lunedì quindi
per l'appunto dicevamo cinque momenti
fondamentali
partiamo dal primo l'invenzione
l'immenso che consiste nel trovare gli
argomenti a sostegno della nostra tesi
che mi ricordo la necessità di spostare
l'interrogazione il compito di storia
alla prossima data utile la legge del 3
ci consiglia di addurre sempre 3
argomentazioni non una di più che
appesantirebbe eccessivamente il nostro
discorso n'è una di meno che non
renderebbe troppo efficace
troppo poco efficace quindi troppo poco
funzionale al nostro scopo che è quello
di convincere l'interlocutore la nostra
professoressa nel caso specifico le
nostre tre argomentazioni potrebbero
essere scarso preavviso col quale siamo
stati informati dell'inter
dell'imminente interrogazione la vastità
del programma di storia da ripassare è
l'importanza di questa interrogazione ai
fini della valutazione finale di storia
passiamo quindi al secondo momento la
disposizione come intuirete consiste nel
trovare una scaletta una disposizione
logica alle nostre argomentazioni
secondo lo schema maggiormente
utilizzato anche dallo stesso cicerone
si era soliti iniziare con l'argomento
di forza media cosiddetto di forza media
cioè l'argomento né il più forte nel più
debole della nostra argomentazione per
passare attraverso molto brevemente
attraverso l'argomento di forza debole
l'argomento debole e finire poi in
bellezza con l'argomento cardine della
nostra nazione l'argomento forte che
servirà a dare il colpo dei nazi
all'interlocutore e quelli in dura e lui
o lei il convincimento definitivo
nel nostro caso particolare potremmo
orientarci così iniziare con l'argomento
circa la vastità del programma da
studiare argomento forte ma non
fortissimo in quanto di fatto o il bravo
studente dovrebbe essere discretamente
preparato su tutti gli argomenti svolti
durante l'anno scolastico
almeno così si spera passando poi per
l'argomento debole che di fatto è lo
scarso preavviso col quale siamo stati
informati dell'interrogazione in quanto
sempre nostro bravo studente dovrà farsi
sempre trovare pronto per
l'interrogazione ma infine concluderemo
con il vero argomento principe della
nostra argomentazione che è l'importanza
di questa
interrogazione ai fini del destino delle
sorti della nostra valutazione historia
di quest'anno scolastico
passiamo al terzo momento le locuzioni
curzio che è la realizzazione del corpo
anche dal punto di vista stilistico del
nostro discorso è probabilmente la parte
più complessa ma come ci ricordano gli
antichi non contano solo le resse ovvero
i fatti il contenuto il succo del nostro
del nostro discorso il messaggio ma
contano anzi soprattutto in erba le
parole ovvero il modo col quale
comunichiamo quello che vogliamo
comunicare la forma in sostanza da
questo punto di vista potremmo dire che
gli accorgimenti che possono aiutarci
sono moltissimi e servirebbero interi
libri di retorica non a caso quelli che
scrisse cicerone per intenderci ma
possiamo comunque trovare degli elementi
basilari che serviranno a realizzare un
buon discorso appunto per ottenere
questo spostamento dell'interrogazione
di storia dicevamo si può iniziare con
la captatio benevolentia che è un
meccanismo che attuiamo anche in modo
istintivo nella quotidianità ed è
collegato quel fenomeno detto servilismo
fenomeno che in realtà molto più scialbo
e molto meno sottile e funzionale di
quello che rappresenta la captatio
benevolentia la quale per l'appunto come
dice il nome serve a accattivarsi la
simpatia la benevolenza per l'appunto
del nostro interlocutore e lo facciamo
quotidianamente quotidianamente
cerchiamo di far capire alla persona con
cui parliamo comunichiamo che una serie
di aspetti che la concernono ci
piacciono al punto tale da piacerci
ancor prima di iniziare a parlare
attraverso frasi banali come come lei mi
insegna come lei sa meglio di me e altri
simili e quindi la captatio
benevolentiae capite è uno strumento
importantissimo per iniziare al meglio
la nostra nazione in quanto eviterà un
discorso una una comunicazione un
dialogo conflittuale e soprattutto per
preparerà al meglio il terreno
un terreno fertile per raggiungere il
nostro obiettivo che come vi dicevo
quello di convincere gli interlocutori
circa la nostra tesi
l'importanza del pubblico è dato dal
fatto che il public speaking l'oratorio
è anzitutto un intrinseca natura
pubblica e quindi ogni discorso non
potrà mai prescindere dal suo contesto
da un dove da quando e soprattutto da un
chi il nostro pubblico il nostro
interlocutore che nella maggior parte
dei casi sarà colui che decreterà la
nostra vittoria o ci condurrà alla
sconfitta
successivamente ci vengono in aiuto le
figure retoriche molto celebri che
quintiliano definì come deviazioni
linguistiche dalla norma e che
consistono bene che ve ne siano di tutti
i gusti e per tutti i gusti
semplicemente in delle alterazioni
nell'ordine logico sintattico delle
parole o nell'accostamento di parole con
suoni particolari per indurre
determinati effetti speciali attraverso
il testo nel nostro ascoltatore alcuni
esempi di figure retoriche sono la
preterizione omissione col quale con la
quale potremo iniziare il nostro
discorso che consiste di fatto nel far
finta di non dire qualcosa mentre la si
dice vi porto un esempio un conto è dire
non siamo pronti un conto è dire invece
non vogliamo mica dire che non siamo
pronti ma semplicemente che ci
servirebbe più tempo sa questa è
l'ultima interrogazione del quadrimestre
un'altra figura retorica forse ancora
più nota e la perifrasi nota anche come
giro di parole al plurale giri di parole
infatti nel nostro discorso non ne
dovremmo utilizzare il numero più alto
possibile così da allungarlo e da far
sembrare al nostro interlocutore che noi
siamo profondamente convinti di ciò che
stiamo dicendo ma rispettando sempre la
legge dell'incertezza ovvero lasciando
il nostro interlocutore un margine di
dubbio il cosiddetto beneficio del
dubbio che farà sì che qualsiasi sua
decisione non sembrava forzata indotta
dall esterno ma sarà sentita come
intimamente condivisa infine se ci
sentiamo particolarmente poetici
potremmo concludere con una climax
ovvero con l'accostamento
in ordine crescente l'intensità di
parole dal significato simile ad esempio
potremmo dire alla nostra professoressa
promettendole che lunedì ci trovare
pronti le assicuriamo le promettiamo le
giuliano che non è di ci proverà pronti
di storia e speriamo ma ritornando al
nostro modello iniziale abbiamo ancora
due punti la memoria su quello mi
dilungherò molto in quanto consiste
semplicemente nel imparare a memoria o
nella similare comunque menem unicamente
ciò che abbiamo scritto realizzato nei
punti precedenti e servirà ancora di più
a rendere il nostro discorso convincente
a non farlo sembrare la scusa
dell'ultimo minuto per evitare
l'ennesima interrogazione ma soprattutto
l'ennesima insufficienza terminiamo poi
con il quinto momento il momento clou
dell'orazione della preparazione
dell'orazione che consiste nel lazio
ovvero nell'esposizione del nostro
discorso
un'esposizione che dovrà essere sì
scenica ma non teatrale che dovrà
mantenere sempre una diva naturalezza e
soprattutto molta disinvoltura
qui troviamo subito un elemento che ci
ricollega su di psicolinguistica moderni
i recenti del novecento è tuttora in
corso che sottolinea come nella
comunicazione e vi siano tre componenti
quella verbale di cui abbiamo parlato
che consiste che costituisce però
solamente da parte meno importante bensì
le altre due che sono la paraverbale e
che consiste nell'insieme di tono della
voce volume della voce pausa espressiva
e ritmo non verbali che consiste invece
nella gestualità nella
mimetica facciale e anche nella postura
o semplicemente nel modo di vestirsi
compongono insieme il grana grande parte
diciamo del ruolo maggioritario che ha
la comunicazione al nostro fine che è
quello di convincere quasi li collega e
non possiamo non citarlo uno studio
condotto ormai nel lontano 1967 da paul
watzlawick e da altri esponenti della
scuola di psicolinguistica di palo alto
gli assunti nell importantissima opera
pragmatica della comunicazione umana
nella quale sono individuati cinque
assiomi o meno cinque regole nonché
peculiarità inscindibili dalla natura
stessa della comunicazione
e i primi due costituiscono l'anima
stessa dell'opera quindi brevemente il
primo assioma dice semplicemente che non
possiamo non comunicare qualsiasi gesto
qualsiasi parola qualsiasi nostro
comportamento comunica qualcosa di noi
dai rossi silenzi che comunicano la
volontà di non comunicare sino alla
maglietta che indossato e la mattina
prima di questa funesta interrogazione
di storia il secondo si chiama specifica
semplicemente che esistono due aspetti
della comunicazione un aspetto di
contenuto che consiste nel messaggio che
vogliamo veicolare con le nostre parole
è un aspetto di relazione che consiste
invece nella relazione che vogliamo
instaurare con il nostro pubblico
infine non possiamo non concludere
prendendo in analisi brevemente le tre
variabili che sempre insieme
aristotelico individuano come alla base
di ogni comunicazione di ogni discorso
ne sono il nuovo sulla parte nazionale
che concerne il discorso il messaggio è
ciò che vogliamo comunicare e come lo
comunichiamo il pathos che consiste
invece chi ascolta e quindi nella
capacità del duo l'oratore di indurre
nella sfondatore nell'interlocutore dei
sentimenti delle emozioni o
semplicemente dei ricordi che lo
porteranno a provare per il l'oratore
per chi parla simpatia con passione o
persino italia infine network che è il
carattere di chi parla è infatti secondo
il modello è retorico classico ogni
giocatore deve avere credibilità ovvero
e deve saper convincere mantenendo la
propria autenticità e questo è
probabilmente l'insegnamento più grande
di questi uomini dell'antichità che
furono anche i politici interessati di
etica e che non è solo un insegnamento
tecnico ma se l'uomo è parola la parola
e comunicazione anche l'insegnamento
profondo di vita sia presente noi stessi
semplicemente perché oggi non basta
vincere sulla carta bisogna vincere
grazie
[Applauso]